Let them talk, I don't care.
Speaking of Hinode,
he's been acting smug lately.
You think so?
All high and mighty.
What?
His grades shot up. It makes no sense!
He must have cheated on the tests.
His grades were like mine back in--
Muge? What are you planning to do?
-Food food!
-Thanks for the food.
No, don't!
Muge, calm down! Muge!
Someone stop her, please!
What was that about Hinode? Take it back!
-What? Are you crazy?
-What is she...
Muge?
What?
Muge!
What's with you?
This is so much easier when I'm a cat.
-Blood! I'm bleeding!
-Are you crazy?
That's my line!
What?
Hinode is always--
He works really hard!
-Stop lying about him, or I'll--
-Muge!
Are you okay?
"Are you okay?"
-Hey, let's go.
-Yeah.
I'm fine. I'm totally fine!
Were you worried about me?
You should go to the nurse's office.
-It's nothing, really--
-Let's go.
Okay.
You don't have to do that,
I'll clean that up myself.
You can have half of my lunch box.
What? What? Wait, really?
This is... boiled sweet potatoes!
I didn't know you could cook.
-You made all that yourself?
-Yup.
That's incredible!
My dad should learn
a thing or two from you.
Look at that color, that shine!
I bet it's really salty.
Don't complain.
That was a compliment!
It tastes just like my mom's.
You should have ignored those two.
I agree.
They can say whatever they want about me.
But I won't let them
slander you like that.
These boiled potatoes are amazing!
-Hey!
-Muge, what are you doing?
Hinode's boiled potatoes are...
really salty!
You should say it's delicious.
"Really salty"?
I see. Okay! Then...
-Hinode's boiled potatoes are--
-Knock it off!
You don't have to redo it!
Why?
His rice may be salty too, Muge.
Shut up!
Did I just make Hinode laugh?
Don't go jumping off
buildings again, okay?
You're not a cat.
Ta-da!
She has the same scent.
Eat up, Hinode. Don't be shy. Open wide.
It's my lunch box, okay?